[Music]
your husband David Benioff created
co-created Game of Thrones and what's
interesting is about that and people
love that show is that when he first
told you about the idea did you not tell
him I think it's not that's not gonna
work I'm gonna come off so badly on this
show they're like haha yeah yes I
thought it was a terrible idea
terrible what what is it you thought was
terrible Billy Ray Dungeons & Dragons
but real with real people right it seems
like I'm on your side on this because if
someone pitched me the idea for a lot of
shows I would if I just heard the idea I
would say I don't think that sounds
great then you see the amazing cast the
great stories the storytelling I am on
your side
thank you if someone came up to someone
and they said there's gonna be this guy
with orange hair dances around it's
gonna be a show it's terrible but then
you see it and it becomes a sensation
hey you clearly love the show now now
you gotta love the show my chest and
just this afternoon I went to my
husband's office to tell him can you do
the school run or ask him something and
the board the storyboards were up for
the next season in index cards on my
left and I literally was like David
David can you pick up Frank
my wife talks to me but for different
reasons look at me you pale free
you